لكن يبدو ان الرقائق الالكترونيه امام
ازمه اخرى فالعالم بين خيارين الصحه
والتقدم التقني مع محاولات لخضر مواد
كيميائيه تدخل في صناعه هذه الرقائق
الالكترونيه نتحدث هنا عن فئه من المواد
الكيميائيه المعروفه باسم بي اف اي اس
التي تدخل في انتاج معظم الاجهزه
الالكترونيه وايضا الكهربائيه لكن تم
ربطها بعده امراض منها السرطان عده دول
حاولت حظر هذه المواد وضعت لاستخدام مواد
اخرى بالفعل عملت شركات على ايجاد بدائل
منها
اكبر شركه لتصنيع الرقائق في العالم التي
قالت انها تحقق تقدما منذ عام 2006 في
تايمز البريطانيه رصدت ايضا سلبيات حظر
هذه المواد في حاله في هذه الحاله تحديدا
سيتعين على العملاء قبول ان المنتجات
الاحدث ستكلف سعرا اكبر مع غلاء المواد
الاوليه جمعيه امريكيه اشارت الى ان
القيود على مواد
بي اف اي اس يمكن ان تؤثر على صناعه تدعم
سته ملايين و200 الف وظيفه وتساهم باكثر
من تريليون دولار في الناتج المحلي
الامريكي وفي حين تعترف بعض جماعات الضغط
في صناعه الكيماويات بان الشركات ستحتاج
الى قبول حتميه فرد قيود الا ان الافضل
لها قد يكون الحصول على اعفاءات مؤقته
اخيرا قال مختصون لفاينشل تايمز ان التخلص
الكامل من مواد بي اف اي اس لن يكون ممكنا
على المدى المنظور لكن ربما يتم التخلص
منها بنسبه تتراوح بين 70 و80 في المستقبل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات